30 with brian loftis denise valdez and
ted florendo 8 news now live at 6 30
live vocal now
and good evening and welcome back
another big week for the vegas golden
knights three straight home games here
to talk about the recent home success
and the return of mark stone we say good
evening to our hockey expert derek
england and boyd derrick how fast are
these weeks flying by i gotta ask as a
player do they fly by as fast as the
fans i don't think it goes by quite as
fast there's lulls in the middle of the
season that kind of drags on and on and
um you know this is one of them during
the season that november up until
christmas but uh as a fan right now it's
flying by it's all you know almost
december here and it's amazing that
we're a fifth of the way through the
season already yeah it's
15 games in already it's uh you know it
seems like the season just started how
important is it now to have uh
uh mark stone back on the ice playing
with the guys not only on the eyes but
in the locker room just a guy like that
the captain yeah you you're missing
obviously his talent and uh skill on the
ice and what he does out there but
you're he's a huge part in the locker
room um a voice in the locker room guys
you know he's a calm presence out there
he's always
plays the right way too and he's going
to make everyone around him better and
then when you speak about getting better
how about these young guys that are
scoring their first nhl goals three of
them this past week which was really fun
to see yeah it's always it's an amazing
accomplishment when you get that first
goal i still remember mine
in pittsburgh and
for those guys to get that first one
it's a
day that they'll never forget and
they'll keep those pucks for the rest of
their life how that experience for you
how was that it was fun i was in
pittsburgh i remember sidney crosby and
chris kunitz assisted on it i still have
the sticks they signed their sticks
after the game for me and gave it to me
so i still have their sticks in the
in the closet and just waiting for a man
cave to put them up in
it must be amazing when you think about
not only you playing in the nhl but
you're in your score and your first goal
that you'll never ever forget that yeah
time flies by but it seems like
yesterday you know you get their first
goal i remember it was against tampa bay
i think mike smith was a net and
it was just a shot screen in front and
went in and uh
you know i couldn't tell you any of my
other goals but i won't forget that one
very cool how about the defenseman
you're watching the games now who's
playing well for the golden knights
right now well you got to start the
goaltending has been phenomenal um you
know i think uh
from that toronto game from then on uh
they've kept the
the team in the games and uh it starts
there and i think as a as a unit of five
guys out on the ice they're doing a lot
better uh you know collapsing helping
the goaltender out clearing rebounds and
and getting the puck out of there
they're breaking out a lot cleaner now
and
which is less defensive zone coverage
well they got three more games this week
some big ones at home carolina's playing
really well then detroit and columbus so
three important games again yeah three
three teams from the east it's uh
they're
all playing well um they played detroit
not too long ago so they know what
they're about but uh carolina 11 and two
i believe right now so it's going to be
a big test for them tomorrow night all
right once again
derek thank you very much for dropping
in again perfect weather for hockey here
in the desert and for a look at your
forecast here's ted
hey